est il préférable pour l'humanité d'être
libre de prendre des décisions qui
aboutiront probablement à sa propre
destruction
ou bien doit-elle s'en remettre au
contrôle des machines pour son confort
et son bonheur au prix de sa liberté
que souhaitez vous le plus
croyez vous possible d'avoir les deux
moi je ne donne pas de répression
je me contente de poser les problèmes
dans mon livre la fin de l'éternité
je présente ce choix entre contrôle et
sécurité ou bien liberté et danger dans
les robots je choisis contrôle et
sécurité dans la fin de l'éternité
je choisis liberté et danger donc en
parcourant mes livres vous pouvez me
voir prendre différents points de vue je
veux présenter les pièces du dossier
dans un cas comme dans l'autre c'est au
lecteur de choisir
évidemment c'est facile de poser des
problèmes de dire vous avez le choix
et vous alors quel est votre choix moi
mon choix je ne peux évidemment ne
parler que pour moi ça n'a rien à voir
avec le sort du monde qui exige peut
être contrôlé et sécuritaire
mais ce que je choisis moi c'est la
liberté de danger vraiment je pense que
plus la technologie sera avancé plus
chacun aura droit au chapitre
peut-être même que c'est seulement par
un surplus de technologie que nous
pouvons avoir une réelle démocratie à
l'échelle planétaire
une démocratie où l'opinion de chacun
contrat ou le moindre sujet en
entraînera un vote rapide une chacun
recevra une éducation bien plus efficace
où chacun sera mise au courant des
problèmes et des solutions possibles
supposons que les ordinateurs soit
développée au point qu'un jour ils
deviennent intelligents peut-être plus
intelligent que l'être humain un
ordinateur vraiment intelligent plus
intelligent que l'être humain est à mon
avis supérieur à l'être humain et doit
contrôler plus étroitement l'univers je
ne vois là rien de criminel
au cours des trois milliards d'années ou
plus qu'a durée d'évolution de la terre
les organismes plus efficaces ont
toujours remplacer les organismes moins
adapté nous ne nous indignons pas du
fait que les mammifères entérite et de
la terre à la mort des reptiles géants
et nous tombons d'accord que le primate
homo sapiens est sans doute le plus
prospère des mammifères alors si nous
l'admettons il est juste que des espèces
encore plus perfectionné nous remplace
être plus perfectionné que l'homme c'est
être plus intelligent que lui
ces espèces plus intelligence auraient
été créés par l'homme alors bravo autant
à notre crédit mais voilà nous ne sommes
pas absolument sûr de m dans
l'ordinateur les ingrédients qui
constitue notre cerveau nous n'en savons
pas assez sur le cerveau
notre cerveau est si compliqué qu'il est
très difficile pour l'homme d'en
comprendre le mécanisme
on essaie de comprendre le cerveau
humain avec le cerveau humain
or la seule manière de le faire est de
réunir plusieurs cerveaux sur ce
problème
c'est cela peut se compliquer au point
qu'un ordinateur devient nécessaire pour
formuler les résultats voilà alors si
les ordinateurs nous aide à comprendre
les mécanismes du cerveau
cela nous aidera à sortir des sentiers
battus pour devenir plus intelligent
plus humain
les machines s'améliorant nous nous
améliorons aussi bien sûr je nage sans
doute dans l'utopie mais peut-être aussi
qu'un jour l'homme et la machine se
dresseront ensemble face à l'unive ma
série de lives fondation fondation et
empire est une épopée politique
elles expriment les vues les individus
sont sur une large échelle les
marionnettes de mouvements sociaux qui
les dépasse il est impossible pour
l'individu de remonter le courant de
l'histoire humaine
au fond peu importe notre action le
mouvement nous entraîne c'est une sorte
de déterminisme social et cette série a
été écrite dans les années 40
j'avais alors 20 ans sigean les écrivais
aujourd'hui j'allais écrire et peut-être
différemment